[Musique]
le président du département accompagné
des élus de la commune de salazie de
bras panon a inauguré la maison
départementale de salazie un
établissement qui regroupe une partie
des services du département dédié à
l'action sociale à la petite enfance et
à l'insertion
une quinzaine d'agents spécialisés
proposent un accueil et des services au
plus près de la population de salazie la
maison départementale enfin elle la
baule répond aux attentes de la
population en termes de proximité des
services du département se doivent
d'être au plus près de nos populations
surtout celles et ceux qui ont besoin de
constituer des dossiers dans le domaine
de ce sociale l'amélioration de
l'habitat des les dossiers pour les
personnes âgées la paix accédera donc
tout cela
tous ces dossiers peuvent être montés
ici ici c'est un lieu d'accueil un
guichet qu'on offre à la population de
salazie et ensuite nous offrons aussi
donc poids des services à la petite
enfance
on le voit bien donc des structures pour
les familles qui n'est pas des enfants
ici dearlove ses possibilités d'être
accueillis dans de bonnes conditions
donc en fait c'est une maison
départementale comme on souhaite en
avoir sur tout le territoire des
équipements de proximité en lien avec
l'action sociale du département
[Musique]